tu viens de trouver un objet d'étude est
une question de recherche es tu ne sais
pas ce que tu dois faire maintenant tu
vas commencer l'exploration mais tu ne
vois pas très bien comment s'y prendre
je m'appelle sylvain draps mais je suis
professeur de sciences sociales en
belgique et dans cette vidéo je te donne
quelques clés pour débuter ton
exploration l'exploration c'est l'étape
numéro deux de la démarche des sciences
sociales si tu n'as pu en tête cette
démarche je te renvoie vers cette vidéo
qui te donnera les bases méthodologiques
pour comprendre l'ensemble de la
démarche
l'exploration comporte en fait trois
grands types de tâches les lectures les
entretiens exploratoires et dans
certains cas des méthodes d'exploration
complémentaires dans cette vidéo je
n'aborderai que les lectures il faudra
attendre d'autres vidéos pour que je
vous présente ce que sont des entretiens
exploratoires et les méthodes
complémentaires les lectures c'est en
fait l'ensemble des documents que tu va
consulter dans cette phase de recherche
le premier objectif va être de
confronter des représentations je te
propose cette vidéo dans laquelle
j'explique le danger de celle ci dans le
cadre d'une recherche de sciences
sociales dans un deuxième temps
l'exploration va te permettre de faire
ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
universitaire les tables art mais c'est
pas un coureur
[Musique]
l'état de l'art c'est en fait vraiment
le tour d'horizon de l'ensemble des
connaissances et des recherches qui ont
été réalisés par rapport à un objet
d'étude tout processus scientifique part
de l'état actuel des connaissances le
lien social n'est pas des sciences on ne
va pas chaque fois repartir à zéro sinon
la science n'avancerait jamais mais ce
tour d'horizon ce panorama des
connaissances déjà existante va te
permettre aussi de trouver les concepts
les modèles d' analyse que tu pourra
emprunter à différents auteurs pour
constituer son propre modèle d' analyse
donc tu ne peux pas te passer de
l'exploration sous peine de faire une
recherche
prat terrible un chercheur qui ferait un
cherche son aux explorations mais
finalement ne ferez que vérifier ses
propres représentations de l'objet par
rapport à tout ce que l'on peut trouver
sur internet ou même en bibliothèque
comment faire pour choisir les lectures
il y a beaucoup de choses à lire et
personne n'a le temps de tout lire et
certainement pas un élève du secondaire
et il va falloir beaucoup lire qui n'a
ni le temps ni les compétences et
parfois vous ou le manque aussi de
motivation donc il va falloir être
stratégique dans le choix des lectures
et je le dis souvent aux élèves un bon
élève c'est un élève qui est un peu
fainéant récemment j'ai bien dit un peu
tout d'abord la principale arme pour
réaliser une bonne sélection de thés
lecture va être ta question de départ
trop souvent les élèves disent ah
monsieur j'ai trouvé ceci c'est super
intéressant à ça je vais je vais le
garder celui-là mais il c'est super
intéressant
et ça ne répond pas du tout à leur
question de départ si tu trouves
vraiment cet article très très très très
intéressant
bien à ce moment là il faudra peut-être
juste modifié ta question de départ ce
n'est pas interdit mais attention si tu
modifies licence est à question de
départ tu risques de ne jamais avancé
dans sa recherche
et ça c'est la première chose et c'est
la principale chose à retenir donc si ta
question de départ n'est pas terrible je
t'invite à la reformuler de suite alors
comme l'élève doit être un peu fainéant
a bien on va d'abord se contenter des
textes les plus courts
pour se faire une idée rapide de l'objet
d'études souvent on essaiera d'avoir des
textes dans lesquels il y a déjà des
références donc des sources qui sont
cités et ce qui permettra de rebondir
sur ces sources c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que je conseille toujours une lecture de
l'article wikipédia wikipédia évidemment
on ne peut pas se contenter de l'article
de wikipédia mais dans wikipédia il y a
des références sur certains articles que
tu pourra consulter et donc cet article
wikipédia pour être le point de départ
de ce tas recherche nous on peut trouver
aussi d'autres articles qui font le
point sur des études déjà réalisées
comme des articles de presse ou des
articles de vulgarisation
si vous décidez d'aller vers des
articles scientifiques des articles
universitaires qui ont été publiés dans
des revues scientifiques
alors je te conseillerai dans un premier
temps de te focaliser sur l'abstract qui
est le résumé proposé au début de tout
article scientifique dans cette abstract
l'essentiel est dit et donc ça me
permettra de directement savoir si cet
article est intéressant pour toi ou pas
généralement avec l'abstract l'intro est
la conclusion qu a fait le tour de
l'article il ne faudra pas forcément
rentrer tout de suite dans le corps de
l'article surtout situées à un élève du
secondaire parfois c'est juste suffisant
il faudrait que tu sélectionnes aussi
des sources qui sont explicative parfois
on a des articles de presse ou des
articles de vulgarisation qui ne le font
que décrire une réalité c'est sans doute
très intéressant mais ça ne sera pas
suffisant tu peux te contenter d'un
article comme ça très descriptif il
faudra très vite trouver des articles
explicatifs les articles explicatifs
c'est ce qu'ils vont donner des facteurs
qui vont donner des variables
explicatives par rapport à ton objet
d'étude c'est pas forcément facile à
trouver mais c'est bien là qu'est la
difficulté de l'exploration ces deux
correctement explorer je te conseille
également d'aller sur des sources
synthétique parfois on a des recherches
de 30 pages ou des bouquins très
intéressant sur le sujet
cependant il n'aura pas le temps de tout
lire dès le départ quoi peut-être que le
bouquin sera intéressant par la suite
mais ici tu es vraiment en phase
d'exploration en tout cas au début de
cette exploration moi je te conseille de
ne pas lire directement un bouquin sauf
si tu es vraiment un grand lecteur
évidemment content de toi aussi de
l'introduction la conclusion voire de la
table des matières pour savoir si ce
bouquin est vraiment intéressant et
pourquoi il n'est pas nécessaire de lire
un lit complète mais simplement un
chapitre ailleurs beaucoup d'ouvragés
scientifiques ne sont que des
collections d'articles et finalement
vers le bouquin tu as plusieurs auteurs
qui ont rédigé différentes parties donc
ça peut soutenir de manière tout à fait
séparés aussi enfin je te conseille
d'aller vers des sources complémentaires
des articles complémentaires on pourrait
accumuler des articles redondant tu dois
essayer de trouver vraiment des points
de vue complémentaires je t'invite aussi
évidemment à faire une critique des
sources pour chacun des articles que tu
vas sélectionné je te mets cette vidéo
dans laquelle ge explique ce qu'est la
critique des sources et comment bien là
réalisé un certain moment des idées ne
seront plus très clair je te conseille à
ce moment-là de t'arrêter et de faire le
point parce que là j'en peux plus de
prendre une feuille de papier décrire
les idées de chacun des articles que tu
as déjà retenu ou vraiment avoir des
idées claires ça peut être aussi
l'occasion de faire le point avec tes
pairs ou avec tes proches voir avec ton
enseignants si c'est possible si nous
avons cours de sciences sociales
ensemble tu peux venir évidemment me
voir et on pourra discuter de tout objet
d'étude et de comment trouver des
articles des lectures intéressantes par
rapport à celui ci
ce temps de réflexion je l'appelle le
temps de tabouret c'est un temps
vraiment on va se poser et réfléchir et
après tu aura sans doute meilleure
vision de ce que tu dois encore chercher
dans son exploration voilà donc quelques
conseils pour débuter son exploration
dans d'autres vidéos j'expliquerai où
trouver des articles facilement mais
aussi comment les lire la société
c'est aussi un compte instagram sur
lequel je publie des contenus beaucoup
plus accessible et plus ludique il ya
également la page facebook sur laquelle
je partage différents articles qui
traitent de faits sociaux comme ça tu
pourras peut-être trouver des idées pour
ta recherche et n'oublie pas le site
internet trois fois w sociaux tech.com
sur lequel tu vas trouver l'ensemble des
vidéos de la chaîne n'est vraiment
classe et pour que tu puisses tu y
retrouver facilement je te souhaite bon
courage pour ta recherche un bon travail
et surtout beaucoup de plaisir car oui
prendre du plaisir en jouant les
sciences sociales et je te dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
oh